this video is brought to you by Dollar
Shave Club support this show and our
super long videos by getting started
with Dollar Shave Club today you can get
a shave that starter set for just 5
dollars go to dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash bio graphics more about
that in a bit for now let's get on with
it on over the 22nd 1963 24 year old Lee
Harvey Oswald fired the shot that would
change history as crowds cheered on
Dealey Plaza the former Marine
sharpshooter put a bullet through the
head of America's telegenic young
presidents it was the first successful
assassination of a u.s. president in 62
years but Oswald he didn't live long
enough to celebrate his grim achievement
not two days later Oswald would be dead
two killed by an assassin's bullet while
in police custody
it's a story you've doubtless heard many
times before but it's only a fragment a
single chapter in the vast and messy
novel of Lee Harvey Oswald's life born
in 1939 - in New Orleans widow
Oswald was a man who tried his best to
live a life of adventure he enlisted in
the Marines he defected to the Soviet
Union he flirted with spies in Mexico
City but it was a single shot fired in
Dallas that would cement his place in
history join us today as we explore the
life of America's most notorious
assassin
when Lee Harvey Oswald opened his eyes
on October the 18th 1939 he had no way
of knowing had just been born into a
world paralyzed by tragedy not two
months earlier the boy's father Robert
Oswald senior had died of a heart attack
leaving his heavily pregnant wife
Marguerite to look after their two sons
these dire circumstances may explain the
dislocated early life that baby Lee
experienced in 1942 Marguerite sent
Lee's older brothers away to boarding
schools she tried to drop Lee at the
local orphanage but was told that he was
too young undeterred she simply waited a
year and then had him admitted and so
began the incredibly depressing
childhood of Lee Harvey Oswald for the
next few years young Lee bounced around
between orphanages relatives homes
apartments Marguerite managed to briefly
finds and just as quickly lose all you
name it in 1952 when the boy was 12
Marguerite's even took him with her all
the way across the country as far from
the bias and old colonial piles of
Louisiana as she could she took him all
the way to New York City
but if Morrow's Wald was expecting these
streets in the Bronx to be paved with
gold she soon got a dose of cold harsh
reality life in New York City was hard
Marguerite's took a job at a dress shop
but it required her to work back raking
hours as in which her young son was left
to his own devices as a consequence Lee
Harvey Oswald's entered his teenage
years lonely and rootless spending long
listless days kicking his heels at the
Bronx Zoo or aimlessly riding the subway
technically he was supposed to be in
school the fact that did not go
unnoticed by the truant officer who
picked him up one day in 1953 by this
point 13-year old Lee had moved over 20
times in his short life usually after
Margaret's latest job or latest
relationship blew up in her face
the boy was surly withdrawn prone to
violence he even sometimes threatened
others with a pocketknife so rather than
just caution this way with child the
truant officer sent him to a psychiatric
facility there he was found to suffer
from neglect but no actual mental
illness he was just another
directionless kid with too much time on
his hands and no one to love him but
while the love situation wouldn't change
Lee's life was about to get
a whole lot of direction on June the
19th 1953 Julius and Ethel Rosenberg
were executed by electric chair at New
York's sing-sing prison
handing us secrets to the Soviets the
execution galvanized New York's leftists
who campaigns across the city in the
weeks leading up to the execution
handing out leaflets one of those
leaflets made its way into the hands of
teenage Lee Harvey Oswald for the first
time in his life the boy encountered
socialism as the Rosenbergs bodies were
quietly buried liebe started reading
books on socialist thought it was an
observation that survived even his next
major move in 1954 Marguerite abandoned
New York City and dragged her son back
to New Orleans and in Apartments on
exchange alley in the French Quarter
today the French Quarter is famous as a
tourist hotspot in 1954 though exchange
Ali was the seediest part of a seedy
City crawling with pimps prostitutes and
mobsters they even had a connection to
the local mafia a virus uncle Charles
Merritt it was a world that Lee couldn't
wait to escape from in 1955 the teenager
applied to the Marines lying about his
age but he was found out and rejected a
year later at age 17 he tried again and
this time he got in in 1956 Lee Harvey
Oswald officially became a member of the
United States Marine Corps he likely
hopes it would be the start of a new
chapter in his life a way to escape his
problems when your problems are as
deep-rooted
as Lee Harvey Oswald's were escaping
them he's easier said than done
[Music]
so here's the thing about joining the
Marines if what you really need is a
place to settle and call home the
reality is it's not gonna happen no
sooner was his training complete than
Lee Harvey Oswald was shipped off to
Japan before being shipped off to the
Philippines and then back to the US yep
it was his wayward childhood all over
again only now the weapons he carried
were bigger than a pocketknife while in
the Marines Oswald managed to gain
certification as a sharpshooter he also
develops an interest in banned weapons
and interests that got him in a lot of
trouble when his forbidden pistol
accidentally discharged and wounded him
the discovery of Oswald's pistol led him
to be court-martialed which led him to
be court-martialed again when he got
angry and attacked the sergeant who was
caught marshaling him
the Soraa debacle ended with Oswald
spending time in the brig when he
emerged it was more bitter than ever
that's not to say Oswald's time in the
Marines was all a disaster the young man
he continued to study Marxism and he
learned Russian he even began preaching
about Marx's ideals to his fellow
Marines and in no to any drill sergeants
out there if one of your Marines
suddenly starts being or pro-soviet in
the middle of the Cold War it's totally
okay to tell the FBI oh and that
definitely goes double if you happen to
be living in 1959 bands because on
January the 1st of that year Fidel
Castro overthrew the Cuban government
and installed the first communist
dictatorship in the Americas we don't
know precisely how Oswald reacted to
this news but we do know he intensified
his efforts with his Russian by now a
clear plan was forming in the young
Marines Minds a plan that would help him
escape his problems once and for all on
September the 11th 1959 Oswald got a
hardship discharge from the Marines just
nine days later he boarded a boat to
Europe where he intended to apply to a
Swiss College he never made it the
moment Oswald reached England he boarded
a flight to Helsinki there he applied
and soon got a Russian tourist visa on
October the 16th 1959 Lee Harvey Oswald
officially crossed to the Soviet Union
barely had the ink dried on his entry
stamp than he declared to his Russian
guide that he wanted to defect
thanks to spy movies we tend to imagine
the Soviet authorities we're always on
the lookout for Americans willing to go
red in reality it didn't quite work like
that
Oswald wrote to the Kremlin telling them
he wanted to
fact the Kremlin took one look at his
application and we're all like good the
rejection it hit Oswald heart on
November the 21st the day his visa ran
out he slipped one of his wrists in his
hotel bathtub
in hospital Oswald was again interviewed
by the KGB again they decided he wasn't
effective material so Oswald he forced
their hands on October the 31st the
newly discharged
Oswald stormed into the US Embassy in
Moscow and declared he was going to
surrender his citizenship was he was
going to tell the Kremlin everything
that he knew about us radar codes in the
- storm that followed the Kremlin
reluctantly agreed to reopen his case On
January the 4th 1960 they finally
approved Oswald to defect to the Soviet
Union when he got the news Oswald must
have felt like partying finally it had
happened he had found a way to escape
his overbearing mother to escape his
wandering to escape his American life
now he would have a place in this world
at last a home to call his own a home
known as Belarus what a lot of freezing
cold January day Lee Harvey Oswald was
ordered away from glamorous Moscow to
the grim gray streets of the Belarusian
capital of Minsk rather than a fresh new
start the move would soon turn out to be
a horrendous mistake if you never been
to Minsk and we mean it with all
sincerity when we say lucky you you
should know it's a city that will never
win any tourist Awards rebuilt in a cold
Stalinist style following its total
destruction in World War 2 Minsk is Kiev
without the charm tricia now without the
nightlife warsaw without the edge
stepping off the train there in the dead
of winter in 1960 mister felt only
slightly less depressing than stepping
off the Styx River into the underworld
still Oswald's new life it wasn't
without a certain charm Minsk in 1960
wasn't a city that was used to seeing
Americans the moment Oswald arrived he
was treated like a celebrity not only
that the Kremlin gave him a luxury
apartments luxury by USSR standards and
a plush job making radios with all this
adulation it was kind of easy for swell
to forget what a precarious position it
put himself in is kind of easy to
pretend as marine
charge being downgraded undesirable
might not cause him problems in the
future it was only after about six
months when locals were used to him and
the novelty of defection had worn off
that Oswald realized that he was now
living in a boring foreign city with
nothing to do it probably didn't help
that the KGB was openly monitoring
Oswald's entire apartment
it was bugged and informants watched his
every move by February 1961 Oswald was
writing in his diary my work is drab the
money I get has nowhere to be spent as
my Russian improves I become
increasingly conscious of just what sort
of a society
I live in barely a year after it first
arrived in Minsk
Oswald began petitioning the US and the
USSR to let him return to America but
the America that existed was not the
same as the one Oswald had left the
previous November a telegenic young man
had narrowly squeaked whom to victory in
the US presidential election known as
John F Kennedy he was the youngest
elected president in American history
but the JFK prayed much on Oswald's mind
that yet no sooner had he decided to
leave Minsk than he found a reason to
stay in mid-march 1961 Oswald met Maria
Prosecco ve' by chance at a trade union
dance well there was supposedly by
chance
marinas uncle worked for Soviet
intelligence and it's long been
suspected that he engineered marinas
meeting with the American regardless the
two hit it off and a mere six weeks
later on April the 30th 1961 they got
married thirty nine months later on
February 15th 1962 Marina Oswald gave
birth to their daughter June it was at
this time that Lee Harvey Oswald began
taking his return to the USA very very
seriously aware that finding work in
America with an undesirable discharge
hanging over him would be difficult
Oswald came up with a desperate plan
he wrote directly to Secretary of the
Navy John Colony asking for his
discharge to be scrubbed in return he
Millie got a glossy leaflet asking him
to support Connally for governor of
Texas this was more than just a slap in
the face to Oswald's mind it was like
Connally had personally urinated on him
and then seduced his mother
from that moment on Oswald would begin
nursing a grudge against Connally that
would soon grow to murderous proportions
a desirable discharge or not they the
Oswald's family petitioned to return to
the USA it was gaining
it turns out Oswald had never
surrendered his American citizenship
despite threatening to do sir back in
Moscow when this came to light there was
little the Americans or Soviets could
realistically do to keep their family in
Minsk on June the 2nd 1962 Oswald marina
and their baby daughter June or receive
permission to return to the US they
headed straight for Fort Worth Texas
where they moved in with one of Oswald's
brothers just like that Oswald's career
as a professional defector it was over
he was now back in the land of the free
and it wouldn't be long before
Oswald was using those freedoms to buy
himself a gun but you know what I think
you should by Dollar Shave Club because
one it's awesome and two because for
just five dollars you can get started
with an amazing product and support this
show that's a win I use Dollar Shave
Club to shave my head we're see not my
beard I used to use the cheap razors
from the store I always end up cutting
myself it was just a generally bad and
bloody time but I also didn't want to
buy the super expensive ones that Raptor
and all the crazy plastic with all the
security stuff it was just bad choices
either expensive or crap but then Dollar
Shave Club comes along and they have
quality without the crazy price tag just
$5 at Dollar Shave Club gets you an
executive razor three tubes of shaving
stuff this a scrub shaving butter and a
post shave do also they have an oral kit
and a shower kit those are just five
dollars each as well if you want them
the toothbrush it's great stuff my old
brush I've had it for way too long
months and months and months the
bristles they were it doesn't matter I
got a new one from Dollar Shave Club
it's awesome the shower stuff is also
great too but look at me I'm a man with
a big head to shave and the razors are
where it's at for me so if you want to
buy one thing from Dollar Shave Club get
that five dollar razor kit and then if
you want get the dental one get the
shower one as well it's just five
dollars each so just go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash
biographic get started with just five
dollars if you've ever thought about
supporting biographic s-- and what we do
here Dollar Shave Club it's a really
easy way to do that so please go check
it out there's also a link below
[Music]
so even Oswald's past you're probably
expecting to hear how his return to
America was marked by the feds dragging
him off a lengthy interrogation no white
baby while the FBI did check in with
Oswald the CIA didn't even bother to
send anyone out to talk to him that is
of course unless you believe the
theories that say that the CIA did
debrief Oswald but then destroyed the
evidence after JFK got shot in order to
cover their tracks
either way comes summer of 1962 Oswald
was living in Texas he was looking for a
job and this was not a happy search
rather how he said his undesirable
discharge might be a massive deal when
looking for employment well it turned
out to be that absolutely massive deal a
great many places turned Oswald down
after learning about his unhappy break
with the marina's according to people
who knew him Oswald responded to those
setbacks by blaming the man who had
refused to scrub its discharge John
Connolly but not even an undesirable
discharged defector is completely
unemployable in October of 1962 and
Minsk emigres Friends of Marina finally
got Oswald a job in Dallas but there was
something else that had caught Oswald's
magpie mind by this time and that was
Cuba baffle Oswald began to obsess over
Castro's new Cuba he started to tell
people Kennedy was a terrible president
for authorizing the 1961 Bay of Pigs
invasion a bungled attempt to overthrow
Castro it was at a Dallas party in
February of nineteen sixty-three that
Oswald added these views to one volkmar
Schmidt Schmidt snorted and told us well
that he should be far more angry at
Edwin Walker an ultra rightist Walker
had been forced to retire his post as a
general for teaching his soldiers
fascist ideas something about Walker's
story at court Oswald's imagination he
began to stalk the former general and
not long after he ordered a pistol and
rifle through the mail Moreno was home
late at night when Oswald came bursting
through the door white as a sheet
babbling that it shot him him was Edwin
Walker less than an hour earlier a
single bullet had come through Walker's
window just missing the ex-general the
shot had been fired by Oswald
who'd buried the rifle and fled the
Dean convinced that it killed Walker it
was only when marina turned on the radio
that was well realized that it missed
not two weeks later Oswald he vanished
from Texas and this this is where we get
into the really mysterious part of Lee
Harvey Oswald's life we know he
eventually resurfaced in New Orleans but
the timeline of what he did there is all
confused
proponents of the theory that the Mafia
killed Kennedy believe Oswald spent his
time in New Orleans getting connected to
the mob virus uncle Charles Merritt
regardless of whether or not that's the
case we do know he took a minor job at a
coffee company and sent for marina and
June to join him but all of this was
just a sideshow
Oswald's real interest in New Orleans
was Cuba that may 1963 Oswald founded a
pro-castro group handing out leaflets in
the streets and trying and failing to
recruit new members yet he seems to have
been playing some sort of game in August
los walt approached an anti-castro group
and offered his services the group
turned him away
still Cuba remains a powerful drawer in
the young man's mind
he appeared on local radio twice to
defend the Castro regime in September he
told marina he was planning to hijack a
plane and fly it to Havana eventually
this strange dream completely consumed
the dreamer on September the 25th
Oswald vanished from New Orleans just as
suddenly as he had vanished from Dallas
his exact movements that night are
unknown years later an anti-castro
activist in Dallas would recall a man
named Leon Oswald showing up on his
doorstep and asking for money to help
the guerrilla war against Castro the
activists refused regardless we know
exactly where Oswald walls by
mid-morning the very next day he was on
a bus bound to Mexico City and he had a
plan that would make his defection look
like a mere warm-up act
[Music]
at the height of the Cold War there was
no more shadowy city in the Americas
than Mexico City officially Mexico was
neutral but officially it was a hotbed
of clandestine meetings dangerous games
and spies gunning to get the drop on one
another into the setup for a Graham
Greene novel walked one of the most
shadowy men of them all leo v oz Wald
arrived in the Mexican capital on
September the 27th
after an all-night bus journey Elliott
he dumped his bag in the hotel room then
he was making for the Cuban embassy
Oswald had made up his mind he was going
to defect to Cuba all right so you might
remember how initially the US was like
oh yeah we're really not interested dude
well Cuba they were even more like yeah
man just no rebuffed Oswald went to the
Soviet embassy and tried to get a
transit visa through Cuba presumably
hoping to defect when he landed but
again these Soviets were like it's not
happenin so Oswald went back to the
Cubans he literally begged them to take
him but they refused broken Oswald left
the Cuban embassy five days later he was
on a bus back to Dallas his shiny new
dream in tatters at least that's the
official version the unofficial version
comes from reports by CIA assets in
Mexico City when Oswald arrived they
paint a very different picture the spy
June Cobb reported Oswald had been
spotted at a party attended by Cuban
diplomats while there he was overheard
joking about killing JFK another asset
claimed to have seen Oswald at a
separate party conversing with two
Americans these two men they've never
been identified it's pretty spooky stuff
now whether you believe the official or
unofficial versions there's no denying
that Oswald was back in Dallas by
October the 3rd exactly two weeks later
he took the job at the Texas School Book
Depository from this point on the story
of Lee Harvey Oswald takes on a feeling
of inevitability on October the 20th
morena gave birth to Oswald's second
daughter just three days later
Oswald clandestinely attended a
right-wing rally being held by Edwin
Walker the general had tried to shoot on
November the 1st the FBI came knocking
at marinas door she was living with a
friends after a row with Oswald and was
surprised to discover
feds wanted to talk with him when word
reached Oswalt he became jumpy on
Tuesday November the 19th a local Dallas
paper published the route the
president's motorcade would take through
the city on Friday as well noted that
the car would pass right by his place of
work he also noted that Governor John
Connally would be riding along with the
president's finally on November the 21st
Oswald went to the house of the friends
that morena was staying with
incidentally the same place had left his
rifle for safekeeping
that evening he tried to make up with
morena three times each time morena
refused
Oswald wound up spending the night in
the garage his rifle beside him and that
was how things stood as the clock ticked
towards midnight and November the 22nd
1963 officially began President Kennedy
was on his way to Dallas and Oswald was
just a nobody who dreamed of being a
somebody in just over 12 hours that
dream would become a nightmarish reality
[Music]
the morning he ends of the history books
Lee Harvey Oswald woke up early moved
his wedding ring and left some money
alongside the sleeping morena
he wrapped his rifle in paper and took
it with him to the 6th floor at the
Texas School Book Depository at noon
Oswald's fellow workers they clocked off
for lunch he told them he would be right
with them then he patiently waited until
they'd all filed into the elevator and
laughed before going back to retrieve
his rifle at 12:29 p.m. exactly as
advertised the presidential motorcade
swung onto Dealey Plaza as John F
Kennedy waved at the crowds the wife of
Governor John Connally leaned toward the
president and said mr. president you
can't say Dallas doesn't love you those
would be the last coherent words Kennedy
where ever hear as the clock ticked over
to 12:30
there was a distant crack of a gunshot
if you watched the Kennedy footage
carefully you can see that Governor
Connally the first shot he reacts and
starts to turn around and then the
entire sensible world shattered into a
billion pieces there was another crack a
bullets went through the president's
throat and hit governor Connally causing
him to slump forwards in the car Jackie
Kennedy grabbed her husband asking him
what was wrong up on the sixth floor of
the Texas schoolbook depository Lee
Harvey Oswald took aim with his rifle
again five seconds later came the third
and final crack President Kennedy's head
jerked back with the force of the bullet
and the screen faded to black the rest
of that fateful afternoon you already
know the images of panic in the streets
are seared onto our minds the sound of
Walter Cronkite's voice disbelievingly
telling the nation that President
Kennedy is dead you know to the way
Oswald fled the scene only to shoot
officer JD Tippit dead less than an hour
later you likely remember the story of
how Oswald tried to hide in a movie
theater only to be arrested shortly
after at midnight that same day Oswald
was booked for assassinating the
president and paraded before the press
it's only with hindsight that we can
look at photos of that moment and notice
Jack Ruby lurking in the background by
the time the clock ticked over and
November the 22nd 1963 receded into
history nobody on earth had any doubt in
less than 10 seconds that afternoon a
single man had pulled a trigger
and changed the world the dream was over
nothing would ever be the same again
[Music]
after the drama of the previous day
Saturday November the 23rd 1963 was
eerily quiet in Dallas Lee Harvey Oswald
sat in a police cell protesting his
innocence outside a local strip club
owner names Jack Ruby hung around asking
every copy saw what time Oswald would be
transferred to another Jail the only
thing of note that really happened that
day was the first of Rodd cast of the
long-running British sci-fi series
Doctor Who but we're gonna guess maybe
the people in Dallas were a bit too
occupied to care about that thus if
November the 23rd passed in stunned
silence November the 24th would be
marked by the crack of a nothing gunshot
at 11:17 a.m. that morning dallas police
led Lee Harvey Oswald's out into a
waiting crowd to be transferred to
another facility no one noticed as Jack
Ruby sauntered down the ramp towards the
prisoner murder in his eyes no one
noticed the revolver being raised the
sudden movements there are photos you
can find if the exact moment Oswalt was
shot his mouth is wide open his eyes
bugging out of his head the crowd of
policemen they look blandly at him as if
they haven't realized what is happening
Oswald collapsed into a pool of blood as
he was grabbed by the lease Jack Ruby
was heard to shout you guys couldn't do
it I did it for you I had to show that a
Jew has guts I'm happy that I got him
less than two hours later at 1:07 p.m.
Lee Harvey Oswald was pronounced dead
and that's really the end of our story
there's simply no time here to go into
the endless theories that grew in the
wake of Oswald's own assassination
linking him to the Mafia to the Cubans
to the Soviets to the CIA no time for
the Warren Commission no time to even
check back in with Jack Ruby dying of
cancer complications in his cell On
January the 3rd 1967 remorseless to the
end perhaps the only thing we should
mention is the little green book Secret
Service agent Mike Howard found in
Oswald's apartment the one with a kill
list written in US and governor colonies
name decorated with daggers of Kennedy's
name there was no sign
even this is just a distraction from our
main narrative there are plenty of
videos out there on the JFK
assassination if you want theories on
who did what and why they're only a
click away
but our job today it was to tell the
story of not the conspiracy but of the
men at the heart of it and that job is
now done Lee Harvey Oswald was laid to
rest at Rose Hill burial Park Fort Worth
on November the 25th 1963 the exact same
day John F Kennedy was interred at
Arlington Cemetery
finally after 24 years of researching
Oswald had at last found his home so I
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that like button
below also subscribe but most of all
please do check out our fantastic
sponsor Dollar Shave Club at
dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash bio graphics there's also
a link below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]